if you actually tried to picture graves
number in your head then your head would
collapse to form a black hole that's
actually that's not just some sort of
crazy sort of pictorial image it would
it would that we - what you couldn't
store that much information in your head
people think mathematicians just
basically look at bigger and bigger
calculations and bigger and bigger
numbers which is not entirely true but
Graham's number I love because it's the
biggest number that's been used
constructively well because there's a
sort of maximum amount of or we call
entropy that can be stored in your head
and the maximum amount of entropy you
can store in your head is related to
this - a black hole the size of your
head and the entropy of a black hole the
size of your head carries less
information then it would take to write
out Graham's number so the effort
ability is have you started to try to
write out greater number in your head
then your head would eventually have so
much information that it would collapse
to form a black hole
you start with a small number and three
three is a small number what you can do
is you can start adding three to itself
so you could do 3 plus 3 plus 3 you keep
going in fact what I've done here is
I've multiplied 3 by 3 right so you
could just do 3 times 3 that works just
as well and if you want you could do
lots of these you could do 3 times 3
times 3 and you can multiply it lots of
times and that is well that's 3 3 cubed
okay and that's 27 so we're happy with
that I could write this another way the
way I would write this down in arrow
notation would be I'd write 3 arrow 3
and that just means the same thing 3
multiplied by itself three times
hopefully you're still with me at this
stage
now I say what's 3 double arrow 3 you do
3 to the power 3 to the power 3 we would
write that as that is 3 ^ ^ 3 this means
3r o 3r o 3 now what does it well 303
I've already seen it that's 27 so 3
arrow 27 okay and 3 arrow 27 well that's
3 to the power of 27 if you actually
work that out it comes out to be around
about seven point six trillion now at
this point you can go wild right how
many how many arrows do you want so the
next one let's say we did 3 ^ ^ ^ our
arrow or whatever you want to call this
our three well that that that that that
is equivalent to three to the to the
double to the double to the three to the
double to the double to the let's 3 ^ 3
^ 3 ^ 3 and that stack that stack is
seven point six trillion threes high and
you start from the top and work your way
down and you get an almighty number you
get a number there's absolutely off the
chart you couldn't write these numbers
down
depends in the universe don't forget
just three three stacked together or
seven point six trillion now we've got a
stack of 37.6 dream of them hi
and the question is why would you want
to know right and so actually the reason
we have our notation is to look at very
huge numbers the famous the
quintessential never-ending what does
end it's finite number is Graham's
number and it's the solution to a mass
problem so in math we do things called
combinatorics where you look at big
combinations and we look at things
networks which mathematicians call
graphs and you look at different ways of
our coloring in graphs and some
mathematicians looked at ways to color
in effectively graphs that are linked to
higher dimensional cubes so I bare with
me for all this you can get cubes in
higher dimensions and look at different
ways to color them in and they tried to
count the number of Decatur I've got
I've got an analogy there's a very
famous analogy for how this works so
imagine you've got a group of people so
you could have for example are three
people trying to have a relaxing time
drinking champagne you can then try and
select committees or subsets and that
group of people you can put some people
in one committee some other people in
another committee and you know some
people can be in a few committees and
there's a lot of bunch of committees
that you could put together and then
what you do is you say okay I've got all
these committees and I'm going to sort
of pick pairs of committees okay so I've
got a bunch of pairs you know committees
can form pairs and you each committee
can be in more than one pair and so on
and then you say okay I've got all these
pairs of committees and I'm going to
give them a color each pair is going to
have a color blue or red okay now I ask
the question how many people do I need
there to be in the first place to
guarantee that there are at least four
committees for which let's get this
right there are four are there are four
committees each pair made out of those
four committees as the same color and
all people appear in
I forget and for which each member of
that committee is in an even number of
committees the ultimate question is if I
put these weird conditions on those
links of matching up different
committees what's the smallest number of
people required for that to be true so
that's the question that gray was trying
to answer in a very roundabout sort of
way so he said okay fine but he wasn't
applying it to committees or was to
something now is to do a hicap
hypercubes in extra dough in higher
dimensions but it's the same question
essentially and they worked out that
there is an answer it's not infinite and
the answer is not bigger than Graham's
number and Graham's number was developed
in 1971 as being the maximum possible
number of people you need for this to be
true at the same time they worked out
the smallest number which was six so
somewhere between six and grains number
is your answer however to actually see
Graham's number we have some more paper
we use arrow notation to get to grains
number except we start and I use threes
for a reason because you start with a
three arrow arrow arrow arrow and you
call that your first number and that
notation is to call that G 1 and already
don't forget how mind-boggling this
number was last time this is this is
this is already off the chart right it's
call this stupidly big ok right now we
say well it's G 2 well G 2 is a 3 where
we've got a lot of arrows how many hours
have we got we've got G 1 of them okay
so this was stupidly big this is
stupidly stupidly big right and then we
carry on we do G 3 and we get a whole
bunch of arrows how many well you
guessed it G 2 of them and then the
thing is that you're getting numbers
which are beyond arrow notation right
just ah and then you keep going right
and grains number is if you keep doing
this you keep doing G's right you go all
the way down to G 64 equals grains
number so it's just unimaginably big I
mean literally that's great number what
do we know about Graham's number well we
don't know what its first digit is we do
know its last digit its last digit is 7
now let me know about its last 500 this
last one is 7 people say how big is it
right and you can't even describe that
how many digits this nothing you can't
you can't even just like the number you
would need to say how many digits there
are yourself you couldn't describe how
many digit and then it's and so the
answer to this problem is somewhere
between 6 and Graham's number recently
though mathematicians have narrowed it
in even further I think it was early
2000 someone pulled it in to be between
11 and Graham's number right so we're
narrowing it right we're going to get
there as far as mathematicians are
concerned 11 to the biggest number ever
used constructively is quite precise
right because no matter how big a number
you think of Ryan this is just stupid
big it's smaller than infinity right
there's still an infinite number of
numbers that are bigger than Graham's
number right so frankly we've pretty
much nailed it as far as I'm concerned
yeah I mean it's it's it's not the
largest number to have been used in it
in a mathematical proof there's the sort
of tree theorems that use larger numbers
now but you know back in the 70s it was
it's just an interesting little anecdote
about about Graham himself he was there
actually a circus performer as well as a
mathematician so he was certainly did a
few circus tricks earlier okay what with
this